what's your advice for teenage
entrepreneurs learn i think podcasts are
excellent way to do that i i've seen
you've got loads of books here yeah i'm
a terrible reader i don't like reading
at all but reading books would be good
as well but for podcasts for me hearing
someone's voice i've listened to that's
much more like storytelling i could hear
it i can hear the inflection in
someone's voice i get it i would say
listen and learn but also do you can
read and learn first your life and never
do a single things you have to start at
some point so start something which is
not going to cost you a lot of money
start something and just get some
experience under your belt and then
obviously you should be able to apply
some of the things you've heard in the
podcast and if you're not making
progress then something's wrong so
course correct and do something
different don't worry about it don't
commit don't like spend six years
planning something and then realize it's
going nowhere you can do lots of things
quite quick and easily now and if they
start getting a bit of traction and
double down on they don't get any
traction and move on something else
[Music]